Death is still a mysterious and unknown subject
for all of us.
We see it often in our favorite films and
books, but what's the real scoop on it?
Here are five surprising facts about death
you would have never guessed.
One: When a person dies, their hearing is
the last sense to go.
Although not scientifically proven, Zachary
Pallas, a medical director, believes that
hearing is the last sense to go when we die.
He states that when death seems near, family
and friends always share their last thoughts.
Although it becomes clear that blood pressure
is dropping and the person is fading out,
we often believe they can still hear what
we're saying.
Two: You can't actually die of old age.
You've probably heard this many times, but
you can't actually die because you're getting
old.
Instead, people often die from inactivity
or disease that comes with aging.
As far as records show, old age hasn't been
scientifically recognized as a direct cause
of death.
Three: People see a white light at the end
of the tunnel before they die.
Give us a thumbs up if you always thought
movies only did this to be dramatic, but this
is actually true.
David Hovda from the UCLA brain injury research
center, says that most of your regions in
your brain shut down right before it's time
to go, making it hard for you to process things
visually.
This is why it's only possible for people
to see a white light and nothing else.
Four: Out-of-body experiences are common in
near-death cases.
Researchers in Switzerland can explain this.
Apparently, when you have a near-death experience,
it causes the right side of your brain to
be stimulated giving you those sixth sense
fives.
It can feel so intense that you may get the
sensation that your body is floating in space.
Five: Facing death will give you transformational
potential.
We understand that death is scary for many
of us, but our attitudes towards death can
play a big role on a transformational potential.
Dr. Steven Taylor says that when we face death
directly and accept it for what it is, we
can surpass anxiety's and live our lives to
the fullest.
Which of these facts did you find most intriguing?
Do you have anything else to share about death?
Please share your thoughts with us below.
Also, don't forget to subscribe to our channel
for more helpful tips and share this video
with others.
With your help, we can reach more people and
provide our support.
Thanks for watching you!